NARRATOR: This
picture is creepy.
There's no other way to say it.
One tattered doll missing
the top of its head
slumped up against the wall,
next to another doll wearing
a baby-sized gas mask.
But it turns out this is just
the tip of the creepy iceberg.
The place where this photo
was taken is full of scenes
just as nightmare-inducing
as this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The person responsible for this
haunting photo is this guy.
TIM KNIFTON: Hi, my
name is Tim Knifton.
I'm from South Wales
in the United Kingdom,
and I'm an urban explorer.
Photographs taken in one
of the many small nurseries
within the abandoned
city of Pripyat,
which is part of the
Chernobyl exclusion zone.
NARRATOR: On the morning
of April 26, 1986,
the Chernobyl Nuclear
Power Plant in Ukraine
suffered a terrible accident,
resulting in explosions, fires,
and the deaths of 28 people.
It also sent harmful radiation
into the air, which forced
an evacuation of the area.
And still to this
day, no one is allowed
to live within 30
kilometers of the site.
This is the Chernobyl
exclusion zone,
and it is still a very
dangerous place to go.
TIM KNIFTON: Being
urban explorers,
we've all got our bucket
lists, or our wish
lists in terms of places
we'd like to go and visit.
Chernobyl is one of the sort
of top places on my list
that I wanted to see, not just
for photographic opportunities
and to explore the
buildings, but also
from a historical perspective
because it's a place that's
obviously rich in history,
however bad the disaster was,
and to also see it
with my own two eyes.
NARRATOR: The city of Pripyat
sits in the exclusion zone,
and is something of
a time capsule now.
The sudden evacuation
left no time for people
to gather their things.
Schools, amusement
parks, and homes
are just how people
left them 30 years ago.
TIM KNIFTON: Just to see these
buildings before they fall down
forever, and just to see these
old relics, these old items
where people were
evacuated from their homes,
and their businesses,
and their place of work,
and just really seeing
how time has stood still
and just to see the
element of decay
and how the place
actually stood,
and how it still stands today.
NARRATOR: And still,
between the radiation
in the air and the
crumbling buildings,
it's a very dangerous
place to visit.
But it was well
worth it for Tim.
TIM KNIFTON: As
an urban explorer,
I wanted to see this
site for a long time.
It's in the top 10
abandoned places to see.
Just part of my
sort of wish list,
I wanted to go and
see these places.
Some people I work with call
me mad because, you know,
go to a place like
that that's the subject
of nuclear disaster,
rather than go
on a beach holiday in
their eyes is pretty crazy.
NARRATOR: If you
liked this video,
check out this one
on dark tourism
destinations around the world.
MAN: While following a
tour, the tour's idea
is to show the damages of the
deadliest Wenchuan earthquake
in recent history.
NARRATOR: And don't
forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]